um
yeah we're just going to keep it on i
guess
all right
hey
so
uh
okay
30 seconds
what'd they say
bears on the loose
is
do you have anything up
yeah we love anything i would love to
have him open up tonight
okay administration
no i just they're looking for that sound
they're looking to just hear
the mic in fact you know the pool is
funny
here it's fine i just want to know
what's there
test one two test test
over there
i'm sliding down
doctor
um awesome
accepted
uh
good afternoon everyone thank you for
being here
over the past 24 hours the president has
continued to improve
he's met or exceeded all standard
hospital discharge criteria
he'll receive another dose of rem
deserve here today and then we plan to
get him home
it's been more than 72 hours since his
last fever
oxygen levels including ambulatory
saturations
and his work of breathing are all normal
though he may not entirely be out of the
woods yet the team and i agree that all
our evaluations
and most importantly his clinical status
support the president's safe return home
where he'll be surrounded by world-class
medical care 24
7. i'd like to bring dr dooley up to
review some more
specifics
good afternoon just a brief update this
morning as dr conley mentioned the
president uh continues to do very well
his vital signs this morning uh were
notable for a temperature of 98.1
his blood pressure was 134 of 78. a
respiratory rate of 17 respirations per
minute his heart rate was 68 beats per
minute
and his last oxyhemoglobin saturation
was 97
on room air he currently
does not endorse any respiratory
complaints and aside from our
evaluation with the multi-disciplinary
team this morning
has maintained a full schedule
ambulating and working on the white
house medical unit
and i'll turn it over to dr garibaldi
and again discuss therapeutics
thanks
hi good afternoon and again i just
wanted to echo the sentiment of what an
honor it is to to be part of this
this wonderful team here at walter reed
uh yesterday evening the president
received his third dose of remdessevier
he tolerated that infusion without
difficulty and his kidney and liver
function continued to be normal
our plan is to give the fourth dose of
rem desperate this evening before he
goes back to the white house
and we've made arrangements to deliver
the fifth and final dose of his
treatment course at the white house
tomorrow evening
he continues on dexamethasone and again
the plan for today is to continue to be
up and out of bed
eat and drink and work as he is able and
i'd like to turn it over to dr jason
blaylock who's an infectious disease
specialist and the chief of medicine
here at walter reed to give some updates
on infection control
thank you
good afternoon everyone uh first of all
i just want to say
uh what an honor it's been to be part of
this medical team behind me
and to care for the president since the
president's arrival at walter reed
he's received medical management that
remains in line
with national clinical societal
guidelines
uh for treatment of copin 19 infection
in addition
both myself and dr west campbell have
worked very closely
with various laboratories in the area
state-of-the-art facilities to include
usamrid and rare
on obtaining advanced diagnostic testing
to really inform the white house medical
team of both the status of the president
as well as his ability to transmit virus
to others
also we have worked very closely with
the walter reed team
to ensure that we are looking very
closely at
infection control prevention strategies
and the right posture
so that the president can safely return
to his residence
and with that i'm going to turn it over
to dr conley who
will answer any final questions
i mentioned it saturday but i'd like to
reiterate myself
just how grateful the president and i
are to the men and women of walter reed
our colleagues at johns hopkins as well
as the many federal
private institutions that we've received
support from
and so long as everything continues on
the track that we're
experiencing right now this time so the
president already tweeted out
is to get him home later today with that
i'll take a couple questions
he discharged back to the white house
when he was given steroids
you've said that he's still on those
steroids those are medicines as
as you know that are usually given to
covid patients who are on ventilators or
um with low oxygen so did you over treat
him and if he's still on that medication
how is it safe for him to return to the
white house
we send patients home with medications
all the time
uh in fact yesterday afternoon he
probably met most of his
discharge requirements safely from the
hospital
and he's returning to a facility the
white house medical unit that's staffed
24 7
top-notch physicians nurses pas
logisticians and uh the unit here the
team here behind me is going to continue
to support us
in that nature
control measures are you taking and how
was it safe for him to drive around in a
cloth mask yesterday
and how is it safe for him now to return
to the white house where there have been
so many cases
how's any of this safe so the
the president has been surrounded
by medical and security staff for days
uh wearing full ppe um and yesterday
uh the u.s secret service agents were in
that same
level of ppe for a very short period of
time
we've worked with our infectious disease
experts
to make some recommendations for how to
keep
everything safe down at the white house
for the president
and those around him um we're looking at
where he's going to be able to
uh carry out his duties uh you know
office space
and um and i'll just say that it's in
line with
everything we've been doing upstairs for
this
for the last several days
please on testing can you tell us when
he had his
last negative test was it thursday was
it wednesday when
do you remember when he had his last
negative i don't want to go backwards
uh for people who are around him i
understand
the contact tracing uh as i understand
it is being done
uh i'm not involved in that um so
or was this uh something he pushed for
so
we try to get patients home and out of
the hospital
as quickly as is safe and reasonable
every day a patient stays in the
hospital
unnecessarily is a risk to themselves
and right now there's nothing that's
being done upstairs here
that we can't safely conduct down uh
home
seven to ten days was a window that
you'd be concerned about i don't think
we're there yet
so do you have concerns about potential
worsening or reversal and what are your
plans for addressing that if it were to
happen
you're absolutely right and that's why
we all
remain cautiously optimistic um and on
guard
uh because we're in a bit of unchartered
territory when it comes to a patient
that received the therapies he has so
early in the course
so we're looking to this weekend if we
can get through to monday
with him remaining the same or improving
better yet
then we will all take that final deep
psy relief
but as i said 24 7 world-class medical
care
surrounding him down there we're not
going to miss anything
that we would caught up here he's
physically going to be in the white
house
and how do what does that look like how
do you keep him safely quarantined i
wish i could go into that more
um but but i just can't one point in
dexamethasone treatment
so that has something to do yesterday we
talked about that
the several little uh temporary drops in
his oxygen and we had discussed that
uh as a team and elected uh to start it
early in case that persisted or worsened
uh the potential risks and side effects
we all discussed
we looked at the data and decided that
uh we'd rather uh you know push ahead on
it
than hold and risk uh you know the
opposite what about ct scans and chest
x-rays
what have you seen from his campaigning
uh as far as travel goes
um we'll see his mental status can you
talk to about whether he has any
neurological symptoms
does he have any side effects from his
medications any fogginess from the virus
no i think you've seen the videos uh and
now the tweets
and you'll see him uh shortly you know
he's he's back yeah
or any inflammation in his lungs at all
so we we've done
routine standard imaging um i'm just not
uh
at liberty to discuss doctors you're
actively not telling us what those lung
scans showed just to be clear
so um there are hipaa rules and
regulations
that uh restrict me in uh sharing
certain things
uh for his safety and his and his own
health uh and
and reasons here how many times you said
his oxygen dropped several times can you
share how many times he was on
oxygen you said you'd we checked the
nursing staff yeah
uh yeah yes yes so he he uh two episodes
like we talked about yesterday
uh and both times that he received a
little bit of oxygen and
recovered immediately
um no it wasn't required he wasn't short
of breath
he wasn't looking ill it was more of us
trying to uh anticipate needs and see
how he responded in both cases
it came right off he didn't he didn't
need it for from very long at all
you were on board air force one for
multiple trips are you at all concerned
about your own exposure and exposure to
the medical team
i i am concerned uh but as the cdc
says there are caveats for essential
employees
that as long as you continue to test
negative
you remain symptom free and you keep a
mask on when you're out and about
which we do inside the hospital 24 7
then then you can carry on your duties
yeah
patient man has he been itchy to get out
of here
the president has been a phenomenal
patient during
his stay here um and he's he's been
working
uh hand in glove with us and the team um
and today got to the point he's holding
court with the with those of us around
him the whole team
going over all the specifics the testing
what the future is
um and uh and we we have been back and
forth on what's safe and what's
reasonable
and he has never once pushed us to do
anything
that was beyond uh safe and reasonable
practice that we all first
wanted against the president leaving
here and going back to the white house
today
the um said don't be afraid of kobit do
you agree with that
should we not be afraid i'm not going to
get into what the president says
his heart liver and kidney function was
normal or improving
um improving does that mean that there
were effects and
is it all normal like what's up with
that yeah it's it's all
it's all normal right now uh i would say
he appeared to be a little dehydrated
uh friday um he
he got he was able to just drink and
recover from that
uh and yeah everything looks great
what sort of things do you think so the
big first thing that we need to do is
that there is no evidence
of live virus still present that he
could
possibly transmit to others and that's
what the infectious disease experts
and some of our partners military
civilian entities doing some of these
advanced diagnostics just to see
as soon as we can identify that
routinely we talk about a 10-day window
you know cdc guidelines
but we we're checking him more routinely
than just waiting 10 days
there's a possibility it's earlier than
that there's a chance that
it's it's a little bit later but we will
know as soon as possible
uh and then we will look at him
clinically how are you feeling how are
you doing
why have you decided not to use uh
administer hydroxychloroquine to the
president during his time here
uh we're i'm not gonna go into all of
our debates about specific medicines and
therapies there are
dozens of therapies that we were made
aware of that we considered that we
discussed and debated and looked at
you know the existing literature on um
and this is the regiment we chose
is he having some of the muscle aches
has he lost his sense of taste and smell
uh no we were just talking about that
what symptoms he has left
and uh he he's he
even the slight cough that he used to
have uh he doesn't really complain of at
all
he hasn't ever complained of uh muscle
aches um
and uh yeah he's he's up and back to him
old self predominantly
next monday just to be clear how long
will he still be actively
shedding the virus um so this this
morning i believe there was even
an accounting by dr fauci referencing a
a five
day the first five days of illness uh
that
you know people are most likely to shed
live virus
there's a reason there's the ten days is
because most people by that time after
seven days
uh most folks don't have culturable live
virus
they put it to 10 just to give some
extra space um
it's never 100 you know between
everybody so
we'll see i can't i'm not going to put a
specific number uh but we
we look at that that window is all i say
or will he be allowed to return to the
oval office we're going to do
uh whatever it takes for the president
to safely conduct business wherever
it is he needs to do within the
residence in white house
is he on blood thinners and also has he
been using
have you been giving him tylenol advil
oh that came up i would like to say he
has not been on any fever reducing
medications
for over 72 hours
yeah he's he's on a a routine regimen
of uh you know covet therapy i'm not
going to go into specifics as to
what he is and is not on um but
that the president had a mild cough from
nasal congestion and fatigue
uh on thursday now back to my uh
colleague john jacobs questionnaire the
reason knowing when the president's last
negative test is important
for that reason your words what you said
and also for the contact tracing
uh but would you recommend it that given
those symptoms that he
uh go that the president go to that
fedminster fundraiser
it's not up to me necessarily uh the
president's schedule but i would say
that
uh it wasn't until after he returned
that we really sat down
then knowing uh the the news of the day
that we really dove into how are you
feeling what's what's going on
those were the symptoms he was
experiencing on thursday i'm not going
to get into
uh you know operations what was his last
negative test and what was his viral
load
i know everyone wants that uh yeah
i don't i don't have his viral load um
those are
some of the diagnostics that we're
sending out that will really tell us
when it's safe for him to get back
out and around people
the last negative test was any abnormal
test any or any of this lab
abnormal i'm not again uh hippa kind of
precludes me from going into too much
depth and things that uh
that you know i'm not liberty or doesn't
wish uh to be discussed
um at some future point maybe uh but
today
sorry i think that's it yeah thank you
thank you thank you
thank you thank you